bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport c'est parti comme tous les lundis
évidemment pour un nouveau tour de
l'actu pop dix départements en 26
minutes
montigny-le-bretonneux accueillait ce
week-end un stage de préparation de
l'équipe de france de baseball qui vient
de recruter une légende de ligue
américaine le québécois éric gagné
focus sur la famille roturier passionnés
de course d'orientation séduit en
courtois l'origine du club sur la ville
à la fin des années 90 ont reçu il ya
quelques jours la médaille de la commune
nous vous ferons découvrir dans cette
édition le floorball ce sport de cross
méconnu en france
cousin du hockey sur glace fait de plus
en plus d'adeptes et notamment des saint
quentinois évidemment comme d'habitude
en fin d'émission tous les résultats du
week end mais tout d'abord on passe au
handball et à la nationale 2
et je suis déjà très bien accompagné sur
la table du 7-8 sport évidemment
philippe l'étrange l'entraîneur de l'ès
montignac balle m'a rejoint bonsoir à
vous on va évidemment parler de cette
saison de nationale 2 et la famille une
partie de la famille roturier et
présentent ce soir pour parler bas de
cette belle médaille que vous avez eue
il ya quelques jours par le maire
françois de lignes et de guyancourt
bonsoir à tous les deux nate si la maman
et quentin un des fils
on va pas tout de suite passé évidemment
au handball le championnat national de
handball reprenait ses droits ce
week-end après la petite pause hivernale
pour cette 11e journée montigny recevez
reims au complexe pierre de coubertin et
vos jose filipe l'étrange se sont
imposés 29 26 vous êtes assez satisfait
de cette performance pour commencer 2014
très satisfait de la victoire
bon malgré des moments difficiles
pendant le match mais bon la victoire
est là et c'était très important prendre
avant de débriefer plus longuement cette
rencontre je vous propose d'ailleurs de
voir le résumé de ce match nous y est on
est chiant ce week-end avec olivier
maniscalco cette rencontre de la 11e
journée de nationale 2 entre montigny et
reims aurait pu basculer en début de
seconde période sur ce coup-franc rémois
lésigny montrent elles perdent leur
machine à buts
la capitaine gabriel par l'horaire
complètement ko ça n'a donc pouvoir à
sanaa fait réfléchir et ça me donne
envie de remettre des bons taquet aussi
parce que je pense qu'elle s'est pris
une belle balle dans la figure ça l'a
mis ko pendant pas mal de temps on a mis
un peu à peu près dix minutes à se
mettre dans le match donc ce n'était pas
évident je pense que ça nous a reboostés
gagné 40 minutes plus tôt montini
démarrent la rencontre à cent à l'heure
pour mener 10 à 3 après 15 minutes de
jeu
vince essaie de limiter la casse en
rentrant aux vestiaires avec cinq buts
d'écart saison secours montigné à la mi
temps tu mets le second acte débute de
la plus mauvaise des manières sur ce
coup-franc rémois gabriel parloir prend
le ballon dans le visage
la lumière s'éteint la capitaine il y
monte elle doit céder sa place
après quelques minutes de flottement les
saint-quentinoises remettre le courant
et maintiennent un écart de trois buts
grâce notamment à une rayonnante fanny
jean baptiste auteur de sept
réalisations dont il s'impose finalement
29 26 et signe là sa quatrième victoire
consécutive
une chose est sûre les joueurs adhèrent
au projet de philippe l'étrange je pense
que le message passe bien on a du mal à
se mettre dedans au départ du site est
quelque chose de nouveau pour nous
maintenant on arrive à se comprendre on
évolue je pense que le contact passe
mais ce départ il a appris à nous
connaître on a appris à le connaître
connaître son mode de fonctionnement et
je pense que on est sur une bonne lancée
avec philippe
un beau cri de guerre pour terminer
avant de parler du match à proprement
dit comment vague avril par la capitaine
ben ça va bien là bien récupéré à la
encore mal au cou donc ce soit bien pour
s'entraîner et non ça va récupérer tout
doucement
c'est pas de chance sur ce coup franc il
a fait don de soi un petit peu un petit
peu oui
sur ce sur ce match là vous voilà vous
gagnez 29-26 vous auriez pu vous imposer
un petit peu plus largement parce qu'il
y avait cinq buts d'écart à la mi-temps
on aurait pu voir une victoire plus
large de montigny son histoire
certainement bon maintenant c'est un
match de reprise on a été en échec au
tir à un moment donné donc ce qui a
permis à reims 2 2 se rapprocher de
rester près de nous alors qu'on n'aurait
pu s'échapper en ce moment vous êtes des
arrivées pardon malgré la blessure de
gabriel
vous êtes désormais 4e au classement
général de cette poule de nationale 2
jours propose d'ailleurs de jeter un
petit coup d'oeil au classement vous
avez fait une belle remontée 1 ces
dernières semaines et ces dernières
journées pourrait être tout près en fin
de compte de la 1re place à seulement
trois longueurs de gagny comment vous
jugez cette position à mi saison
puisqu'on vient de finir la phase aller
c'est une belle position surtout après
le départ difficile maintenant bon le
l'objectif c'est toujours les cinq
premiers donc puis après on prendra ce
qui à prendre si si on doit prendre ça
nous de jouer puis à nous de faire
respecter nos 30 d'allant mais avec une
place
une belle quatrième place on peut rêver
de monter peut-être à seulement trois
longueurs non c'est encore aux rêves les
rôles ont les seins ne l'a pas de côté
c'est pas l'objectif premier on laisse
les premiers rôles et puis on verra mon
maintenant c'est vrai qu'il reste onze
matches dont 8 à domicile et ça c'est
très important pour nous vous parliez
justement de ces huits réception par
rapport à la phase aller où vous êtes
quasiment que des places et là c'est
beaucoup plus intéressant il ya beaucoup
plus de potentiel de matches à gagner
plus facilement
oui c'est ce qu'on dit maintenant bon il
faut quand même courir sur le terrain et
puis jouer notre handball est passé
c'est faire par les adversaires qui vont
être remontés vu nos résultats ont
commencé à peut-être avoir peur donc
être motivés lorsqu'ils viendront sur
mon cri depuis que vous avez pris
l'équipe en main on va dire que la
stratégie en tout cas le projet de jeu
un petit peu évolué vous êtes sûr était
plus axé vers le but et plus je en
lecture voilà c'est tout mais je me sers
du travail de stéphane et bon c'était un
peu difficile au début mon arrivée
malgré que les filles adhère facilement
au projet et ce sont des bosseuses et
surtout une très bonne ambiance comme ça
c'est très agréable de travailler avec
elle oui on le sait montigny le groupe
vit bien est justement un fanny jean
baptiste en parlait le message passe
très bien désormais du monde a appris à
se connaître entre guillemets difficile
où vous parler de ce projet de jeu il ya
un caractère une caractéristique
importante chez chez vous c'est la
défense allait bien agressif peut être
un peu trop sur ce dernier match avec 12
exclusions temporaires c'est un petit
peu beaucoup comme un sens oui c'est un
peu beaucoup maintenant bon c'est les
arbitres ont fait le choix de me sortir
mais il faut se faire respecter et le
handball ça pour moi c'est avant tout la
défense ça sert à rien de marqué 40 buts
si on en use en mai 43 ou 44
donc voilà donc après quand on a la
balle à main bon on est capable
maintenant de faire plein de choses on
est capable de marquer par tous donc ça
c'est agréable et et pas compter que sur
une ou deux joueuses
c'est votre quatrième victoire
consécutive que vous avez signé ce
week-end face à un cinquième match sans
défaite
la belle série continue j'ai envie de
dire on peut encore aller plus loin il
ya des matches importants qui arrivent
bas et de ce week-end contre plus vendre
ou les filles avaient perdu avec
stéphane au match aller donc j'espère
qu'une belle revanche très bien merci
beaucoup merci j'ai les mains de
philippe est repassée évidemment sur le
plateau du 7-8 sport et donc rendez-vous
ce week-end au complexe comme d'habitude
pierre de coubertin où l'on voit la call
of fame c'est alain colas un week-end
d'accord très bien c'est noté coup
d'envoi 20h30 face au septième plouvorn
merci beaucoup le stade jean maréchal à
montigny le bretonneux accueillait ce
week-end à un stage de préparation de
l'équipe de france de baseball qui vient
de recruter une légende de la ligue
américaine
le québécois éric gagné dont l'objectif
sera de remettre au premier plan le
baseball français nous avons suivi
l'entraînement des bleus avec olivier
maniscalco éclair commis seulement 25
joueurs tricolores étaient présents sur
un collectif de 40 unités aux états unis
comme en france les championnats ne
reprenne qu'en mars
les clubs sont donc en pleine
préparation hivernale le rassemblement
est ni mon teint permettait donc de
faire un point sur les niveaux physique
des uns et des autres et c'est une
remise en activité un petit peu parce
que c'est vrai qu'on est en cette
période hors saison donc on est plus sur
la préparation physique des jeunes à
faire un état des lieux un petit peu
leur état physique
ensuite on est bien sur la reprise du
jeu de l'aspect technique
la frap technique de la fête c'est
vraiment le préambule en fait notre
saison sortir formé aux cougars de
montigné est passé par les états unis
frédéric envie est désormais un joueur
cadre de la sélection nationale
pour lui l'arrivée de la légende
québécois éric gagné dans le staff
tricolore va permettre aux bleus de
passer dans une autre dimension
pour l'instant les que france comment
que cette motivation c'est quand on
arrive contre les équipes contre les
pays bas à l'espagne
d'habitude on qu'on sait très bien qu'on
la perd ce match là donc on avec ses
matches face aux motivations sans espoir
et là je pense qu'avec la navette a
gagné ça va changer parce que lui il a
joué à un haut niveau et pour lui ça
vous contre les pays-bas le service l on
s'en fout donc on va essayer de gagner
tous les matches des matches l'équipe de
france devra en gagner lors des
prochains championnats d'europe en
septembre en allemagne pour espérer
terminer parmi les six premiers
on cela les bleus se rassembleront en
mars par la 1ère fois à félix aux états
unis en championnat de france en
division 2 évidemment les cougars 1 que
l'on suit connaissent désormais la
composition de leur poule de saison
régulière qui s'affiche à l'écran les
joueurs d'arnaud faux seront notamment
opposés à vauréal la rochelle ou encore
rennes où ils se rendront lors de la
première journée le 6 avril prochain on
passe à notre entretien
course d'orientation
je le disais dans les titres la famille
roturier passionnés de course
d'orientation d'aiguillon courtois à
l'origine du club sur la ville à la fin
des années 90 ont reçu il ya quelques
jours la médaille de la commune et pour
en parler évidemment nathalie la maman
et quentin l'inde est l'un des frères et
puis un des jeunes champions de la
famille bonsoir à tous les deux tout
d'abord j'avais envie de savoir un petit
peu comment vous avez connu la
discipline d'appel et en fait on a été
expatrié en angleterre en 92 et c'est là
qu'on a eu envie et pour s'insérer dans
le pays de de se mettre dans une
association on a essayé la course
d'orientation on a été conquis et on a
été conquis par la cité familiale qui
était très développé en angleterre et
depuis vous l'avait ramenée en france et
sur saint quentin en yvelines c'est ça
comment ça s'est passé après la création
du club de mieux en cours notamment
mais du coup on a fait plusieurs clubs
et on avait envie un peu de faire une
association à notre sauce et donc quand
s'est définitivement installée sur
guyancourt d'un on a créé notre
association pour faire découvrir le
sport qui a été notre passion quentin tu
étais tout petit j'imagine à cette
époque quand on t'avait découvert lors
de ton portrait il ya quelques mois tu
me disais oh c'était les premiers
souvenirs que tu avais quand j'étais
petit c'était aller en forêt avec mes
parents mon frère ça c'est un souvenir
qui reste gravé moi c'est ça ouais de
l'aller en forêt le dimanche matin avec
toute la famille de chacun qu à chacun
son tour bat mois souvent accompagnés
des parents quand j'étais tout petit et
puis après de prendre le pique nique
tous ensemble dans la forêt puis de
rentrer tranquillement la maison se
souvenir qu'il inscrivait alors vous
créez le club à la fin des années 90
vous n'êtes pas beaucoup 11 aveyron au
départ de famille je crois c'est ça la
vôtre est une autre ça s'est vite
là la mayonnaise a pris très vite sur
mieux encore oui parce que sur la ville
nouvelle il y avait un potentiel énorme
de
personne désirant pratiquer les sports
nature et comme on disait des familles
on était et des adultes et des enfants
et on a tout de suite attiré et des
adultes et des enfants et du coup à
chaque fois qu'il ya de familles qui
arrivent c'est trois ou quatre fois et
d'un le club a progressivement augmenté
en volume et en résultats alors on voit
on va en parler juste après justement
des résultats vous à l'heure actuelle
nathalie vous êtes responsable de
l'école de du club pour les pour les
jeunes notamment
votre mari christophe président du club
faut pas que vous partie de guyancourt
comme on va faire le club sinon ça va
être compliqué non aux personnalités
irremplaçable et je crois aussi que à
titre personnel vous avez un petit peu
vous en avez fait votre métier de la
course d'orientation c'est ça oui j'ai
passé mon brevet d'état et j'ai créé mon
entreprise pour pouvoir faire des
séminaires d'entreprises des team
building à base de course d'orientation
parce que c'est une activité qui
complète la tête les jambes
plein de choses et vous êtes j'imagine
tous les deux très attaché à la ville
aussi peut-être parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d' espaces verts sur la ville nouvelle
ça doit être pour le coureur que tu es
l'orienteur que tu es ça va être très
très important c'est un an c'est
important d'avoir d'avoir surtout de la
forêt à proximité pour pouvoir varier
les terrains à l'entraînement il ya un
domaine peut être un bout de bois un
bout de forêt que vous préférez où vous
allez régulièrement naturellement peut
être entre vous non on essaie de varier
un maximum mais moi personnellement
j'aime beaucoup le forez du manet et la
forêt des votes cerner aussi assez
sympathique vont parler des performances
le club bat progresse d'année en année
un toit quentin tu as été multiples fois
champion de france et il ya eu cette
participation taux récemment aux
mondiaux il y avait eu les championnats
d'europe pressade précédemment comment
vous faites c'est quoi le secret pour
eux voilà à prendre un jeune comme
quentin qui a commencé tout petit puis
le l'amener à l'équipe de france
nathalie c'est pas que notre part c'est
aussi l'heure leur propre tempérament
parce que pour s'entraîner il faut avoir
la volonté il faut y aller qu'il pleuve
qu'il neige et et ne pas trop trop
s'écouter donc c'est clair que la
passion de l'activité on leur a fait
découvrir l'activité et je crois que
s'ils sont passionnés actuellement c'est
leur investissement à eux c'est pas
notre investissement ayant il ya encore
une analyse est en fin de compte rien
n'est normal non avec vous dans ce club
parce que tu as appris ta sélection pour
les mondiaux qui sont passés au début de
l'été à c
de façon assez drôle non je crois oui
c'est un ami qui m'avait envoyé un
message pour me dire que que le coach
l'avait appelé pour lui dire que lui
était pas prier que moi il m'a emmené
pour lui expliquer pourquoi lui était
pas prêt donc c'est lui qui m'avait qui
m'avait envoyé un message pour me
féliciter
et puis même annoncé que moi j'étais
pour le ce grand bonheur qu'est la
sélection en équipe de france
son dernier titre est aussi particulier
nathalie je crois que ça vous a aussi un
petit peu touchés puisque battu était
premier devant ton frère c'était pour
pour qui tu racontes nous un petit peu
ça quentin c'était en 2012
mais j'aime pas france de sprint c'est
une discipline urbaine c'est la cause
orientations mais en ville cette fois ci
donc c'est une discipline que avec
maxime mon frère on affectionne
particulièrement et maxime ça faisait
plusieurs années qu'il courra après le
titre en fait j'en avais très envie et
cette année là ça se dit ça se déroulait
à rennes et puis moi j'y allais sans
grosse pression en fait il s'est
retrouvé que je fais une course propre
sans faute et je n'en trouve cinq
secondes devant maxime donc on fait
doubler tous les deux au moins ça a
commencé
c'est un moment assez fort juste pour
rappeler pour les téléspectateurs tuer
le cadet maxime le grand frère c'est ça
et vous avez quel âge tous les deux de
mots j'ai 17 ans il a 19 ans voilà et a
du coup pour la maman ça devait être un
moment encore plus spécial l'athlète
évidemment mais là un manque mais qu'est
ce qu'elle en a pensé de ce beau podium
mais j'étais fier je suis maman donc
c'est normal et c'est surtout que j'ai
beaucoup apprécié de les voir après la
course courue tous les deux donc
récupéré de leurs courses et comparer
leurs itinéraires savoir pourquoi il
n'avait en levant où l'un de l'autre de
là devant l'autre derrière
et essayer de partager leurs expériences
quelles qualités pour terminer nathalie
on développe quand on pratique la course
d'orientation pour un enfant peut être
déjà la confiance en soi et l'autonomie
comment on comment ça se passe en fin de
compte vous qui est responsable de
l'école quand vous les prenez en cours
quels conseils vous leur donnez il part
tout seul avec leurs deux premières
grandes difficultés c'est effectivement
de laisser partir tout seul parce que la
décision ce qui les prennent et c'est
eux qui les prennent en forêt donc c'est
leur apprendre à être autonome et sans
brûler les étapes pour ne pas qu'ils
prennent peur et une toute dernière
question parce que je la vois depuis
tout à l'heure votre médaille de la vie
qu'est ce que ça représente pour vous
d'avoir été honorés la semaine dernière
par le maire de guyancourt ça représente
ça symbolise un peu tout le parcours
qu'on a effectués depuis 92 ce fil rouge
qui guident un petit peu dans la famille
puisque on peut pratiquer tous et qui
qui continue de dédier de vous guider
encore pendant quelques années je veux
on va la montre est d'ailleurs à la
caméra voilà je me permets comme ça je
n'aurais touché
voilà cette belle médaille de la ville
de guyancourt donné à la famille
roturier
merci vous pouvez tous les deux être
passé sur le 7-8 sport et puis à bientôt
pour de nouvelles aventures j'imagine
dans la forêt puis pour de nouvelles
compétitions merci beaucoup
mathieu vidard et tiny mon teint et
pratique le floorball une discipline
quasi inconnu un jeu je vous l'avouer
n'ya d'ailleurs que dit club en première
division dans le pays et une équipe de
france féminine vient tout juste d'être
créée découverte d'un sport de cross en
pleine évolution
c'est lors d'un séjour étudiant en suède
que mathieu villaret découvre le
floorball rien ne l'indiquent dans le
nom de ce sport mais c'est en quelque
sorte le petit frère du hockey sur glace
ici pas de patin ni de palet mais une
crosse en carbone et une balle creuse
c'est moins technique moins violent
quand même que le hockey sur glace mais
sait il y a tout autant de dépenses ce
physique vraiment on n'arrête pas de
courir on transpire beaucoup et puis ça
reste ludique on a une crosse
il faut pouvoir contrôler la balle faire
des passes à ses coéquipiers
il ya un côté tactique également le
floorball se joue à cinq contre cinq
l'objectif marqué plus de buts que
l'équipe adverse sur un terrain de 40
mètres de long par 20 mètres de large
les rotations s'opère toutes les deux à
trois minutes ici le contact est
interdit sauf à l'épaule et surtout
c'est accessible à tous
très rapidement on prend du plaisir à
jouer ce même si on contrôle pas
exactement la balle on arrive quand même
à faire des passes ou avancés avec la
base même si c'est pas parfait et on
comprend rapidement du plaisir la
légende raconte que le floorball serait
arrivé en france dans les sous sols de
l'ambassade de suède
créé officiellement en 2002 le sport
compte désormais 27 clubs et approche la
barre des 1000 licenciés
il y a quelques mois une équipe de
france féminine a même vu le jour il ya
un gros changement déjà beaucoup plus
des équipes qui ce chalenge et qui
peuvent se battre entre elles
la première division alors pendant
longtemps avec quelques équipes qui est
qui domine est donc automatiquement
on voit que ça se resserre ni votre sert
beaucoup de clubs sont de plus en plus
sérieux à l'entraînement sérieux
certaines cherchent même à prendre à
avoir des entraîneurs dédié les coaches
dédié sur le banc pour débuter vous
devrez vous équiper d'une crosse à 30
euros d'une bonne paire de baskets
adapté et surtout d'un super fair play
tout d'abord place aux baskets et lors
de cette 14ème journée de nationale 3 le
derby entre l'entente le chesnay
versailles et rap a cette fois tourné à
l'avantagé des versaillais qui ont pris
leur revanche du match aller et se sont
imposés 2-3 points 64 à 61 au classement
grâce à cette victoire les joueurs de
romain du bo se repassent devant trappe
à la 8e place et à seulement quatre
points du leader gravenchon c'est dire
ainsi cette poule g est encore très
serré
en basket féminin national donne
évidemment nouvelle défaite de l'entente
au chesnay versailles sur le parquet dit
cette fois-ci 73 à 65 les joueuses de
stéphane relais sont 11e et
avant-dernière de leur poule mais le
maintien reste encore jouable
en rugby 13e journée de le fédéral 3
plaisir accueillez ce dimanche au stade
robert barran vincennes l'une des deux
seules équipes à avoir battu les
plaisirs roi lors de la phase aller
dans une rencontre à sens unique le père
s'est inscrit trois essais en première
période ne laissant que trois petits
points à vincennes au retour des
vestiaires les joueurs de philippe behar
salleron l'addition par deux fois grâce
glanant par la même occasion le bonus
offensif pour finalement s'imposer 36 à
3 ils signent là leur quatrième victoire
consécutive et confortent leur seconde
place au classement avec huit points
d'avancé sur proto cobo et malgré cette
large victoire l'entraîneur plaisir roi
en or est pour le brûle encore un petit
peu plus on écoute on a vu comme tout le
monde qui a eu beaucoup de maladresse
alors est-ce que c'est des premiers
temps froid etc ils ont quasiment pas vu
le ballon de la partie dont j'ai tout le
temps dans leurs 22 mètres on marque
cinq essais alors que je sais pas il y
aurait pu avoir le double
et c'est dû à des maladresses de notre
part donc on va demander aux gens est
encore un petit peu exigeants avec eux
mêmes parce que quand on vise deux
autres tableaux il faudrait pouvoir m
adam un peu plus souvent quand on domine
de cette façon là quoi en football en
division d'honneur ont joué des matches
en retard qui n'avait pas eu lieu
c'était le cas de versailles qui se
déplacer aux mureaux pour le compte de
la 7e journée mais les joueurs de david
giguet se sont inclinés 1-0 et
redescendre à la 12e place du classement
général mais avec encore deux matches de
retard en foot féminin 8e journée de
promotion d'honneur il encourt s'est
imposé sur la pelouse de vauréal 2 0 les
joueuses de dany l'aigle sont désormais
sixièmes au classement de cette poule a
encore deux petites infos avant de nous
quitter tout d'abord du vélo et le
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
qui a ouvert ses portes ce lundi 13
janvier les activités sur la piste la
reine de bmx mais aussi du badminton ou
encore du cev qu'il défend sont
désormais officiellement en route et je
vous rappelle un que l'inauguration
officielle aura lieu le 30 janvier
prochain et que vous pourrez visiter le
site entièrement le 1er et 2 février
prochain lors de journées portes
ouvertes et d'ici là rendez vous ce
mercredi pour un reportage exclusif dans
les coulisses du clairefontaine du
cyclisme français dans le 7-8 l'actu
avec wilfrid richy de la boxe éducative
ce week-end se déroulaient les
championnats régionaux de boxe éducative
catégorie minimes à corbeil essonnes et
le boxing de la verrière décroché pas
moins de cinq titres tenez vous bien
grâce notamment à mine medjahed walid
rahmani ou encore i mais nous a dit
qu'ils se sont qualifiés brillamment
pour les interrégions le club saint
quentinois continue sa progression avec
deux ceintures de plus que la saison
passée on passe évidemment pour finir
cette fuite sport à votre agenda du
week-end deux dates à retenir et surtout
de rendez vous à ne pas rater
football ce dimanche 19 19 janvier place
au 3e tour de la coupe de france de la
coupe des yvelines par nom de football
vous pourrez supporter des réserves de
trappe face aux essarts-le-roi ou
elancourt à neauphle-le-château coup
d'envoi des rencontres à 14h30 tout
d'abord c'est est ce que vous voyez de
sa fille chez holden roland hockey 7e
journée de national 2 les shops
essaieront de décrocher leur première
victoire cette saison avec la réception
de cholet ce samedi 18 janvier à partir
de 20 heures au gymnase chastagner c'est
la fin de ce set 8 fort merci encore une
fois de l'avoir suivi n'hésitez pas à le
commenter un sur twitter avec le hashtag
tout attaché le 7-8 sport
d'ici là excellente soirée sur tv fils à
la semaine prochaine